he went straight at trump specifically
he asked judge barrett about president
trump's refusal
to say that he would peacefully transfer
power
if he loses the election i appreciate
what you've said about respecting our
founding fathers about the originalism
it's remarkable that we're at a place
right now that this is becoming a
question and a topic but i'm asking
you in light of our founding fathers
and loud of our traditions in light that
everyone who serves in that office has
sworn an oath
where they quote swear to preserve and
protect and defend the constitution of
the united states
i'm just asking you should a president
commit themselves
like our founding fathers i think have a
clear intention
like the grace that george washington
showed
to the peaceful transfer of power is
that something that presidents
should be able to do do you think that
the president has the power to pardon
himself
for any past or future crimes he me
he may have committed against the united
states of america well senator booker
that would be a legal question that
would be a constitutional question and
so
in keeping with my obligation not to
give hints previews or forecasts of how
it resolved the case that's not one that
i can answer
well i i think i agree with you that it
is an issue right now something i never
thought would be an issue before
but it is an issue uh yeah i agree with
you judge barrett yeah isn't trump
terrible
because he won't say that he'll
peacefully transfer power you know trump
the guy who won in 2016 and then we
refused
to give up power and you know then he
was president and we the left tried to
overthrow his presidency and we're
continuing to do that
you know you know that guy why won't he
you know the guy
running against democrats our party uh
which just said that joe biden should
not concede under any circumstances that
was that was hillary clinton the
previous democrat presidential nominee
you know that guy yeah can you believe
he won't transfer power
a stupid question trump should never
answer that question don't get
the minute you accept the premise of
that question
you've already lost the idea that you
might not peacefully transfer power
to the left which has spent the last
nine months burning the country to the
ground
so once he moves past that stupid hack
talking point then he moves to another
stupid hack talking point
and asks judge barrett to condemn white
supremacy
i'm going to ask you some questions that
if you had told me five years ago
that would be questions asked at a
supreme court nomination hearing
i would have thought they wouldn't be
possible but unfortunately
i think they're necessary to ask you and
i hope that you'll give me direct
answers the first one
um you've already spoken towards issues
of racism how you deplore it
but i want to just ask you very simply i
imagine you'll give me a very short
resolute answer
but you condemn white supremacy correct
yes
thank you i'm glad to see that you said
that i wish our president
uh would say that so resolutely and
unequivocally as well but we are at a
time
that americans are literally fearful
because their president
cannot do that in the resolute manner in
which you did i'm
i'm sorry that that question had to even
be asked at this time i'm sorry i don't
want it to be asked but it has to be
asked it has to be
judge barrett do you condemn the tooth
fairy uh yes
yes senator booker okay judge barrett i
have to ask this because this is such a
real live issue
not a completely fake contrived issue do
you do you condemn the easter bunny
sure senator booker i condemn the easter
okay i have to i have to ask you that
i didn't know what your answer would be
judge barrett who has two black kids
that you adopted from haiti
i didn't know your answer because trump
trump
won't condemn that super real thing
that thing that's totally real that
millions of people support you know
white supremacy you know that thing
that's totally real he just won't
he won't condemn it right mr president
racism is evil and those who cause
violence in its name
are criminals and thugs including the
kkk
neo-nazis white supremacists and
other hate groups that are repugnant to
everything
we hold dear as americans and you had
people
and i'm not talking about the neo-nazis
and the white nationalists
because they should be condemned totally
we are a nation
founded on the truth that all of us
are created equal we are equal in the
eyes of our creator
we are equal under the law and we are
equal
under our constitution
those who spread violence in the name of
bigotry
strike at the very core of america how
many times do i have to reject
i've rejected david duke rejected david
duke
i've rejected the kkk the klu klux klan
from the time i'm five years old i
rejected them now
i have been asked this question so many
times i have rejected it so many times
i just wish he would give an answer i
just wish he could just tell us
what do you think about white supremacy
you know
in this white supremacist country that
you know that real thing
you know what do you so that's all
they've got they just
make up a bunch of nonsense and then
barrett
absolutely of course smacked it down i
hope you enjoyed that short segment from
the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you